ich habe die orientierungslosigkeit
mitgebracht tatsächlich die ich einfach
fühle jetzt auch verstärkt
in den letzten zwei jahren angefangen
auch mit der korona pandemie im
genaueren ich habe das gefühl dass wir
eine informationsüberflutung haben eine
reizüberflutung wir wissen nicht mehr
genau was stimmt was nicht stimmt und es
werden immer zahlen an den kopf geworfen
aber keiner versteht diese zahlen wir
predigen mit studien von unseren
politischen vertretern dabei sind nicht
alle studien
repräsentativ wie ich finde ich würde
mir mehr objektivität wünschen und auch
noch mal mehr vertrauen in die medien
ich habe so das gefühl dass sehr viel
misstrauen tatsächlich sich entwickelt
hat auch übrigens bei den öffentlich
rechtlichen
einrichtungen nicht nur bei den privaten
häusern und das würde ich mir dann die
öffentlich rechtlichen haben gerade der
top-werte geholt mit blick auf ganz
europa ist sind die deutschen öffentlich
rechtlichen ganz weit oben auf das
vertrauen betrifft aber natürlich gab es
auch ein vertrauensverlust ich würde
einmal frau bekannt fragen gerne wie
sehen sie das mit blick auf die medien
gibt es zu viel informationen zu wenig
repräsentative studien sind sie auch
medien verdrossen
man muss sagen also besonders jetzt mit
dem mit dem krieg ist schon ist sehr
extrem also ich finde es fast schon zu
intensiv vor allem die meinungen sind
alle sehr ähnlich also nicht meine ich
brauche nicht die meinung irgendwie noch
zehn zwanzig mal dasselbe hören sondern
es ist interessant dass man wirklich von
die von jedem kreis vom wirklich junge
leute auch mal die meinungen hört weil
es ist halt schon so ich finde die
jungen leute war nicht so angebunden und
auch so meine generation ich bin jetzt
23 und die leute in meinem alter auch
ein bisschen anders ich meine wir haben
andere wissenszugang allein mit der mit
krone mit der pandemie vor allem zwei
jahre daheim mit mit so am wissenszugang
was wir im internet haben das ist
einfach schade dass man diese leute
nicht so mit einbindet ich finds auch
bisschen krass auch das auch egal
welcher sender jeder sagt auch wirklich
dasselbe es ist wirklich krass und
deswegen schaue ich mir auch
mittlerweile lieber irgendwelche dokus
auf anderen wo informieren sie sich wie
informieren sie sich wenn es um die news
die nachrichten geht die solchen dokus
gibt tatsächlich ich habe meine app ich
habe so meine 5 ab und
an mit bild tatsächlich
klar und dann gibt es noch die welt zum
beispiel und wie man das ist werbung
machen hier deswegen aber auch münchnern
zum beispiel wünschen oder lange in
learning medien kein problem naja es
zeit auch und aber ich finde man muss
sich das schon ein bisschen raus ziehen
und auch es sind auch immer meinungen
dabei und jedes jede zeitung ist ja
schon ein bisschen auch angehaucht
politischen bisschen und das finde ich
schon sehr interessant aber tatsächlich
merkt man jetzt besonders in diesen
letzten zwei jahren es ist sehr
genau also überhaupt nicht spannend dann
lese ich wirklich diesen live ticker und
ließ mir wirklich die schlagzeilen dann
durch und dann von autoren wo ich sagte
okay ist super interessant
lese ich mich mehr ein aber tatsächlich
ansonsten kann ich die zeit präsentation
schon mit doku sonderbar
keine ahnung über geschichte über
politik oder sonst wird also hätten
fliehen können sie es nachvollziehen
jetzt schon die zweite in der runde die
sagt ist etwas sehr viel eine meinung in
den medien
also die transportierte meinung die man
so allgemein deswegen finde ich dass so
ein format wo man sich da mal
austauschen kann wo dann keine angst
haben muss was zu sagen ja und das wird
ja übertragen auf das gefühl wieder
bürgerinnen und bürger also wenn ich da
eben gerade in den letzten 2 jahre denke
wo daneben viele gesagt haben ich sehe
das auch und irgendwie kommt mir das
alles komisch vor und dies und jenes
aber ich rede nicht darüber weil ich hab
das und aus den achten und auf jenes ich
kann mir das auch vorstellen dass das im
medienbereich genauso eine rolle spielt
ich wüsste jetzt nicht ob ich jetzt wenn
ich mich für eine herausragende position
in einer fernsehanstalt bewerben möchte
ob ich dann als der große revoluzzer
reingehen höchste höchste das würde ich
so nicht sehe ich jetzt das ganz genauso
passt übrigens zu allem anderen auch
weil man sich die frage stellt da wären
wir wieder beim bundesverfassungsgericht
aber auch den medien aber auch vielen
anderen öffentlichen institutionen
wo man die frage hat neben die
eigentlich ihren auftrag noch ernst wir
haben in einer demokratie haben wir
eigentlich so eine richtige
rollenverteilung wie in einem großen
theater stück da ist dann die politik da
sind die gerichte da sind natürlich die
bürger als die abstimmenden zuschauer
sozusagen aber auch mit macher aber
nehmen wir zum beispiel auch die
gewerkschaften da hat er wie gesagt der
war ja auch schon bei dtv der masse ja
im februar die neue code governance
gewerkschaft gegründet für die wir auch
mitarbeiten weil wir da auch sehen
gerade wenn viele arbeitnehmer bereichen
dass die leute sagen auch solche
bereiche kommen ihren aufgaben die
traditionell gewerkschaften kommen ihren
aufgaben die nach also das heißt alle
die dinge transportieren wo sie
hingehören kommen nicht nach bin ich
wieder dabei deswegen fangen die leute
an sich in ihren eigenen auch blasen zu
bewegen denn ich kann ja wunderbar im
internet mir ein paar sachen
heraussuchen ich kann also bild und welt
lesen ich kann auch alles andere egal ob
du mir das alles anschauen aber ich habe
damals andererseits bild und welt sagen
freunde der tat das habe jetzt manchmal
wagener das tatsächlich auch ernten aber
immer wenn ich bei 1 tippe wegen
irgendwas kommt sofort gilt aber wer
also fakt ist auf jeden fall
wenn einfach alle sagen mensch nimmt
doch einfach nur eure zugewiesen rolle
wieder ernst ihr müsst doch nicht alle
immer so tun als würdet ihr das rad neu
erfinden wir haben hier verdammt noch
mal ein gemeinwesen das sind sich
demokratie es lebt aber nicht davon dass
es auf dem papier steht sondern lebt
davon dass wir das alles ernst nehmen
und dann können wir auch mit krisen
super umgehen und das wiederum auch für
meine rolle als anwalt einfach zu sagen
wenn ich zum beispiel jemanden vertreter
der mit der maske nicht in der
öffentlichkeit auftreten heißt das ja
nicht automatisch dass ich dann sage den
vertretern ist das ja auch so einer
sondern dass ich einfach sagen ich nehme
ich bin organ der rechtspflege hat auch
eine entscheidende funktion in einem
rechtsstaat und wenn da jemand hilfe
brauchen das unrecht gehe ich mit dem da
quasi mit und nehmen das ernst musste
auch leider sagen auch in der
anwaltschaft gab es da viel in der
vergangenheit die auch gesagt mit denen
will ich nichts zu tun habe ihre leute
dann habt ihr eure berufsbild falsch
jetzt haben wir schon drei von drei
jetzt hoffe ich dass sie ein flammendes
plädoyer für die medien in der korona
pandemie halten also ich fand während
der korona zeit gab es tatsächlich auch
häufiger unterschiedliche ansichten und
perspektiven das muss man sagen
natürlich ganz am anfang in den ersten
tagen da waren ja 95 prozent auch der
meinung wir müssen irgendwie
einschränkungen vornehmen da wusste noch
keiner befragt ich habe jetzt aber geht
nicht die befragung gemacht
wahrscheinlich sondern jetzt nur die die
statistik anzusehen oder diese
der korona pandemie ich kann ihnen gerne
in seinem haus schicken war wirklich 90
prozent zustimmung das gab es noch nie
das war damals dafür hat man auch er
angemerkt also ich land dieser ich bin
jetzt kein demoscope der jetzt hier
legen kann die das mathematisch
einverstanden gekommen ist aber auf
jeden fall das sind ja repräsentative
institute und umfragen nicht die man
kann jetzt über jede nachkommastelle
diskutieren wenn man da spaß dran hat
aber hing damals nicht der trend der war
damals relativ klar und da waren hat ja
am anfang da waren da kam er auf uns da
kam er in den ersten wochen ein extremer
druck auf die politik zu dass man ganz
schnell einschränkte und jeder der über
stadion geöffnet hatte oder irgendwie
zuließ dass eine veranstaltung statt
fahren der war ja wirklich erstmal
gebrandmarkt und dann ist das irgendwann
nicht mehr und dann ist das dann ist das
ja irgendwann umgekippt und dann gab es
medien die auch gesagt haben wir müssen
die
verhältnismäßigkeit wahren wir müssen
auch andere perspektiven im blick nehmen
und wir können jetzt nicht zu einem
zustand kommen eines dialogue downs und
dass diese einschränkung die ja wirklich
an die grundfeste gehen unserer
demokratie und dass die irgendwie der
normalzustand werden und das was ich zum
beispiel auch hier in der nummer gesagt
hat es darf nicht dazu kommen dass man
sagt man muss jetzt die einschränkung
nicht mehr begründen sondern wer diese
einschränkung vornimmt weil eine
katastrophe auf uns zukommt oder weil
wir eine solche pandemie haben der muss
das gut begründen und er kann das auch
begründen das hat er das
bundesverfassungsgericht gesagt aber der
normalzustand muss sein dass alle
grundrechte natürlich bei den bürgern
sind und dass die lok downs nicht der
normalzustand ich habe noch eine
rückfrage ansehen das hat bei weg über
die medien hat gespannt den punkt würde
ich mal sagen ja gern das haben schon
viele dann auch aufgegriffen und ich
fand wir hatten dann auch eine zeit lang
sehr gut der diskussion im land weil das
ja auch nicht immer einfache
entscheidungen waren also man kann jetzt
heldentum auch nach ladenschluss juden
und da ja ich wusste schon immer und wie
entwickelt sich das aber das war häufig
nicht ganz klar und auch viele der
entscheider in der politik die haben ja
echt innerlich gerungen und sich das
auch schwer gemacht das haben sie aber
teilweise sehr schlecht gezeigt dass man
auch mal sagen also auch mit den
umfragen das ist ja wieder sachverhalts
ermittlung wo kommt da war zu recht die
frage wo wurde denn gefragt wir haben ja
wirklich ein querschnitt vieler
unternehmen vieler selbstständiger es
ist natürlich leicht in irgendeiner
position zu sagen ich bleib an um sie in
den kirchen aus der anfangszeit der
panini wir ihn jetzt wirklich wie das
war ja die 34 wahlrecht dass wir das war
eine sehr schnell also ich sag mal so in
der ersten woche aber es war sehr
schnell als es dann hieß da kommt der
lok da sind wir ja insbesondere auf die
gastronomie an die müssen halt aufpassen
dass wir nicht über andere zeitraum
entsprechen weil den ersten drei wochen
können sie mir gerne danach schicken
dann werde ich auch berichtigen in der
sendung später aber in den ersten drei
wochen der pandemie es gab wirklich noch
nie so eine zustimmung in diesem land
das seine teilnahme
wegen
der wichtigen am anfang war das war aber
sonst angesetzt sich sagen das war zum
anfang gerade bei zb den gastronomen die
vollkommen am start waren dann von heute
auf morgen jahre laden zugemacht und
jetzt reden wir über wochen ja ehrlich
gesagt schon eine woche warten zweifel
zu viel unkenntnis wo waren quasi am
anfang die leute die gesagt haben wir
setzen uns hier zusammen guckt mal damit
hier kein größerer schaden entsteht muss
das weiter so gemacht werden und nicht
mit der frage ist muss irgendwann
gekippt werden unsere verfassung
gebietet es unser rechtssystem gebietet
ist dass der staat sich in jeder sekunde
vor dem bürger irgendwas vorschreibt
eingreift permanent erklären muss was er
tut dass es letzten endes wenn der
polizist bei ihnen morgens in der
wohnung steht müssen sie sich nicht
rechtfertigen warum sie nicht reinlassen
sondern andersherum er muss sich im
grunde rechtfertigen warum man in die
tür ergänzen ist die rückfrage ein herr
partien stellen und zwar sie haben das
habe ich am anfang schon angekündigt
wenn wir nicht in einer offenen
meinungspluralismus gesellschaft leben
in welcher leben wir denn dann gerade
ich habe nie gesagt dass wir nicht in
einer offenen pluralistischen
gesellschaft leben
es ist diese frage ist schwierig zu
beantworten was ich auf jeden fall
merken jetzt aktuell beispielsweise die
ukraine krise ich persönlich habe noch
nie mitbekommen was putins startpunkt
ist beispielsweise sie wiederholen immer
wieder der blutige angriffskrieg putins
hört sich auch sehr dramatisch an immer
wenn sich sagen weil es ja auch
automatisch ja absolut aber was will er
denn eigentlich ich sehe unsere medien
was sind denn die interessen was ist in
der alten putin eine rede halten lassen
in den deutschen medien oder was war das
ist der demokratische ansatz dass man
miteinander verhandeln einem auf reden
kann blick auf die ukraine möchten sie
gern so also christian rahn absolut
übersetzt nun wird ja
doch cool wenn wir hierher kommen würden
oder
diskutieren sie aber
liegen würde und diskutieren ich glaube
an gar nichts das habe ich auch nicht
gesagt ich sage der auftrag liegt darin
dass wir in der demokratie
der auftrag liegt darin dass sie
miteinander verhandeln müssten wir
müssen miteinander reden wir müssen
nicht zu den waffen greifen wir müssen
verstehen welche interessen denn
überhaupt hier herrschen warum
richtet aber das ist doch aber so sehr
naiv wenn man ein aggressor und und ein
diktator wie putin hat der will doch gar
nicht mitreden und der wilde nicht nur
dass wir um die diplomatisch mit ihm
verhandeln woher wisst ja er hat
entschieden weil das wurde ja über jahre
praktiziert so mancher jahre sagt man
wenn jemand so zuschlägt also der der
gladius routine der wladimir putin hat
mit russland die ukraine angegriffen da
sind schlimme gräueltaten verübt worden
und sie werden gerade verübt und
wahrscheinlich wenn sie leider auch noch
in hongkong sektion wiederholen und
deswegen müssen deswegen reicht es nicht
einfach nur zu sagen wir wollen mit
putin reden absolut sondern da muss man
ja gegen getreten man muss auch mit dem
geld machen gegen das stimmt solange sie
das irgendwie in der ukraine gelage
oktober muss das problem ich schon eher
sagen sie denen wir müssen mit gut also
nochmal wir brauchen eine aufklärung wir
müssen verstehen welche interessen denn
überhaupt geworden sind ich als
einfacher bürger weiß es nicht weil ich
schreibe nur zur medien ja was berichten
wir denn wir berichten gegangen ihrer
ebenso wie werden damit die ganze zeit
darüber reden wie happiness der böse da
davon reden wir ich verharmlose das hirn
ich möchte ich ihnen gerne verstehen ist
schon für die zuschauer ist einmal kurz
ein es ist nicht so als wäre die ukraine
in russland eingefallen das gibt es auch
nichts zu dem was es ist wir haben
angriffs man an dass das bleibt das
bewerte ich bin auch niemand eine andere
meinung hat man da machen haben aber das
ist im moment stoppt das bewältigt darum
geht es nicht vielleicht reden
aneinander vorbei mir geht es um die
historische aufklärung
was ist das für ein ort seit wann sind
die russen 3 was wollen denn überhaupt
die ukraine welche rolle spielt die nato
welche rolle spielt die usa was macht
deutschland was macht china auf einmal
was mit den gaspipelines welche
geopolitischen
was was man ja das was sie eben
angesprochen ich denn die dortigen mit
zeitung am kiosk kaufen
zeitung oder was auch immer hat
dagegen immer und habe zum beispiel
gegen sanktionen debattiert weil ich die
wirtschaftliche liegt einfach nicht
heile darüber redet jeder auch mal als
jeder die aufbereitung das steht der
ganzen geschichte die beiden das steht
und das ist eben das ding das rosa
angesprochen hat wenn ja auch nicht
dasselbe gemeint und wenn wir sie
informieren möchte muss man sich selbst
darum kümmern weil aktuell und das geht
einher mit ihrem punkt hört man doch
sehr stark immer eine ähnlichen
standpunkt mir geht es aber darum welche
interessen sind denn da ohne zu
evaluieren darum geht es gerade was in
dir lassen denn in freiburg hat sich die
meinung teilt und tatsächlich muss man
ja auch differenzieren wenn man jetzt
eine schlagzeile oder so sieht ja das
ist klar das eine aber man muss ob man
sich das hintergrundwissen aneignet das
ist die eigene sache wenn man sich nicht
für einen hintergrund interessiert dann
ist das nicht die schuld von den medien
oder so sondern oder schreibst du bist
gar nicht das geht nämlich den
journalistischen auftrag nicht jeder hat
die zeit sich darum zu kümmern deshalb
will man das jahren ist und teilweise
manche sachen sind aufgrund bei dem man
hat wirklich also mit dem mieter also
mit dem internet haben wie so ein
wissenszugang alleine schon auf google
eingibt wie nichts man also jeder kann
das eingeben und sich darüber
informieren
deswegen kann man nicht sagen okay
darüber wird nicht genau berichtet aber
ich muss auch zustimmen ihnen dass es
schon so ist das halt man die
schlagzeilen klar sieht und dann gleich
eigentlich schlussfolgert und dann
gleich irgendwie vielleicht das dann
nicht so als ich meine schlagzeile kann
auch nicht ewig lang sein das muss man
auch den medien lassen also man kann
auch nicht irgendwie die ewig groß
lassen bild zum beispiel die haben so
viele fakten und zu hauen so viele
schlagzeilen raus die trotzdem auch
informativ sind aber man kann ich
irgendwie dann auch
noch mal erklären und so das liegt dann
auch in sage ich jetzt mal beim bürger
ob er sich mehr für das thema
interessiert oder nicht
das sehe ich leider nicht so muss ich
sagen ich weiß nein ich würde mir
wünschen dass wir eine transparente und
objektive berichterstattung den
journalismus haben die abos haben sie
das tatsächlich was haben sie aber nie
handelsblatt beispielsweise aber das ist
so mehr so richtung aber das war mir
klar ich lese seit 2001 ein paar mängel
sachverhalt ich sage mal nicht
informiert ja ich sage ich würde gern
den holistischen ansatz dem du dich gern
aber da sind da wird auch berichtet wenn
du herr rede in russland wird doch
überall berichtet von
öffentlich-rechtlichen über bild bis hin
zum handelsblatt es ist noch nicht so
dass man sagen dass es irgendwo hier
nicht berichtet das sage ich auch erst
gar nicht bis kamen so ein bisschen
drüber halten kann das im handelsblatt
schon abgenommen wir sagen nicht dass
gar nicht berichtet wird aber was ich
erkenne ist auf jeden fall eine
einheitliche sprache die erkenne ich die
erkenne ich auf jeden fall ich habe
bisher immer noch nicht im öffentlich
rechtlichen ard oder sagen wir mal hier
ich habe noch nicht herausgefunden dass
putin überhaupt möchte und das ist ganz
sicher nicht nur ein oder zwei punkte
heran problem ist ja bei der frau das
weiß ja keiner so genau das war ja auch
alle gerne wandert in das kloster nein
geht und ich wäre da muss man jetzt
wirklich wieder werden hier irgendwelche
die welt gesetzt
rede ja gesprochen es gibt diplomatie
und er hat sich trotzdem entschieden ein
land anzugreifen und schwere gewalttaten
zu finden ich habe noch nicht machen
gehört noch ein ich habe noch ein jahren
kurz bitte all diese sachen mit
angriffskriegen et cetera die wir gerade
den russen vorwerfen
das haben wir auch schon getan also die
ganze westliche nationen also wir sind
davon jetzt nicht unbetroffen das ist
ein kind das nicht also beide bauten
sind weil er ja und wer das schon mal
gemacht haben daran ist land das jetzt
auch nein es geht nicht ums geld werden